ومن جانبه قال وزير الدفاع السويدي باعل
جونسون ان علاقه بلاده مع تركيا مهمه
للغايه
لمواصله الحوار مع الجان
ب التركي بشان قضايا امني والدفاع
المشتركه في وقت النحل
المانيا
في وقت لاحق
من اسطنبول
لا افاق للحوار التركيه السويدي كما يبدو
من خلال تصريح خلص اكار امير
نعم بالفعل عبد الصمد ويبدو ان مسلسل
الغاء الزيارات الرسميه سيبقى مستمره لذكر
طبعا بانها رئيس البرلمان التركي مصطفى
شنتوب كان قد الغى زياره الاسبوع الماضي
لنظيره رئيس البرلمان السويدي كان مقررا
لها ان تكون في السابع عشر من الشهر
الجاري الان وزير الدفاع يكرر نفس الشيء و
يلغي زياره لوزير الدفاع خلصنا كاره عبد
الصمد كان قد قال بانه اكد اعاده تاكيد ان
تركيا ااه لا ترفض وهي مع فتح باب
الانضمام الى حلف الناتو ولكنه قال وقال
انا اقول بصراحه نحن جلسنا في مدريد هناك
اتفاق الاتفاق كان موجود فيه الامين العام
لحلف شمال الاطلسي همم على السويد وفي
لندن اتخاذ اجراءات وخطوات لمكافحه مواصفه
بالارهاب لكن ما يجرا هو ان السويد لم
تفعل شيئا قال بان هناك مظاهرات له من
وصفهم بالارهابيين مستمره اليوم هناك
دعوات لاحراق القران امام القنصليه وامام
السفاره التركيه في ستوكهولم وايضا لم
تحرك ساكنا قال يجب على السويد ان تتخذ
اجراءات لمنع هذه الخطوات ولمحاسبه
ومعاقبه هؤلاء الذين يقومون بهذه الافعال
لكنها لم تفعل وبالتالي هو اتخذ هذا
القرار لانه هذه الزياره كما يقول لن تكون
ذات فائده طبعا عبد الصمد الاتراك منزعجون
ومستاهون من ردود الفعل السويديه على ما
جرى وخصوصا تعليق النائب العام السويدي
على ان هذه الافعال تندرج في اطار همم
حريه التعبير كان وزير الدفاع وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شو شغله قد علق على
هذا القرار القرار النائب العام السعودي
ووصفه بالسخيف على حد وصفه وقال بانه من
اقامه بهذه المظاهرات التي اساءت لتركيا
ولرئيس التركي هم من الارهابيين على حد
وصفه وان هذه المظاهره
دعت للتحريض دعت للكراهيه بالتالي هذه
جريمه ليس فقط في قوانين تركيا وليست فقط
في قوانين السويد وانما في قوانين كل
العالم وبالتالي لا يمكن وصف التحريض على
الكراهيه والعنصريه بانه حريه للتعبير
وقارب ان السويد تماطل وهي تخدع نفسها
بهذه التصريحات وبالتالي كما ذكرت ربما
واضح ان هناك هذا ال- ال- التوتر سيستمر
بين البلدين
وقربما هذا يؤخر انضمام السويد الى حلف
شمال الاطلس الى انه لن يكون على ما يبدو
هناك موافقه تركيا قريبه في هذا الاطار
اشكرك انظر الى في مراسله الجزيره من
اسطنبول